maybank holiday at east midlands airport
it's been a long time here since the
holiday rush
this week though they should know which
country is on the quarantine free green
list
and what respite there may be for the
ailing travel sector i do think that
it's important to be
cautious in this i we do want to
to do some opening up on may the 17th
but i don't think that the people of
this country
want to see an influx of
of disease from anywhere else i
certainly don't and we've got we've got
to be very very tough
and we've got to be as cautious as we
can whilst we continue to open up
when flights do arrive the system is
straining
or passengers need at least one pcr test
heathrow's boss
says he's worried border force won't
cope when travel resumes
and now a cross-party group of mps
warned that arrival halls with
passengers all mixing together
will be a breeding ground for infection
if i was to point to one area that is
potentially the most uncertain and risky
it is international travel
and the reason for that is as you make
progress domestically you push down
infection you vaccinate the population
then what you need to do is protect that
progress
if you import variants or even import
more cases
you're undermining or threatening that
process and that progress and that's
what you've seen
in other countries around the world who
dealt with their borders and travel to
protect
being able to open up insight there is
of course a balance between keeping
variants of the virus out and supporting
the struggling travel sector two years
ago 80 million passengers came through
heathrow
last year that was just over 20 million
they'd hoped for better numbers this
year they planned for a partial recovery
but that hasn't happened the eu say
they'll reopen travel to countries with
low infection rates by
june but here the sector's still waiting
for its route out of lockdown
cases have continued to drop and
vaccination rates are continuing to
climb so there's every reason
that we can expect a holiday this summer
and when we first
sip that sangria or taste that tzatziki
on our holiday we'll all just forget
about how tough this year has been just
for a short while we need a change of
scenery
we need to see new things experience new
places
from closing borders to the quarantine
rush the last year has brought travel
chaos
[Music]
and this summer there will be more
uncertainty ali
sky news